you're gonna find out where the graph
crosses the x-axis that's where the
y-coordinate is 0 okay so to do that on
the calculator what I've done here is
I've already inputted okay under y
equals you can see X cubed minus 4 x
squared plus 4 I just put in a an
equation here just to show you how this
works go over to graph ok and there's
the graph of the function but what we're
interested in is those points where it
crosses the x axis those are the zeros
that's where y coordinate the Y value is
0 so what we're gonna do now is going to
go back to second calculate and you can
see number 2 is 0 or and press Enter and
what I'm gonna do is you can see here in
the left hand corner see how it says
left bound what we want to do is you
want to arrow just a little bit to the
left okay and above that point where
it's crossing the x-axis so I'm going to
press ENTER and then it over here you
can see it says right bound so I'm gonna
arrow just a little bit to the right but
also below the x-axis I'm going to press
ENTER and then you see how it says
guessed right here you want to hit enter
one more time and it's going to find
that point it's in between those two
points that we picked previously okay
the left bound and the right bound and
so you want to make sure one's above the
x-axis and ones below ones to the left
ones to the right and it's going to find
that zero and you know you've got it
because you can see y equals zero